the biden administration officially
facing a legal challenge over vaccine
mandates arizona on tuesday becoming the
first state in the nation to file a
lawsuit in federal court the news comes
as recent polls show the public may be
losing faith in the administration's
ability to handle the pandemic arizona
republican attorney general mark
brnovich joins us now the basis for this
case attorney general brnovich is an
equal protection uh argument you say
that under the equal protection clause
the vaccine mandate is null and void
because it does not require that
migrants who are coming across the
border illegally and we saw 208 thousand
of them come across the border with the
new numbers in august
make the case for us that because it
doesn't apply to migrants
that the whole thing needs to be voided
well thank you for having me on john and
it's quite frankly as simple as this i
don't think we can have any sort of
serious discussion on covid that doesn't
begin with talking about what's going on
in our border i think it demonstrates
the hypocrisy the abom biden
administration where they're completely
ignoring that problem which we know has
a great effect on us and then literally
what they've done is they've said if
you're a non-citizen you have the option
whether to take the vaccine or not but
if you're a u.s citizen you're going to
be required to take the vaccine and so
that clearly violates the equal
protection clause but secondly i think
it's just really important to emphasize
john is that if you read our lawsuit we
also make the case that the president
himself does not have any power anywhere
in the constitution especially when you
consider the 9th and 10th amendments to
mandate anybody anywhere should get the
vaccine so from jump street our position
is is that this is an unconstitutional
exercise of police powers the president
doesn't have and furthermore even if he
could
he's doing it in such a way that's
completely contrary to the constitution
where he gives people are here illegally
a pass an option whether to take it but
then he's forcing u.s citizens to get
the vaccine which i just think shows the
complete hypocrisy and contradictions
within the binding administration on
that particular point paragraph 12 of
the lawsuit you remind the courts quote
under our constitution the president is
not a king who can exercise this sort of
unbridled power unilaterally and even
george iii wouldn't have dreamed that he
could enact such sweeping policies by
royal decree alone you you claim in the
lawsuit that the vaccine mandate is just
one of a series a greater series of
constitutionally inappropriate actions
john there's a case literally right now
in the fifth circuit where the fifth
circuit enjoined and stopped the biden
administration from halting deportations
this is one of the lawsuits i have and
also with texas where we've said the
federal law says they have to deport
people that have deportation owners they
weren't doing it there is a series of
lawless actions there's this attempt to
concentrate power and whether it's
nationalizing our elections whether it's
these massive tax bills that are
boondoggles for you know left-wing green
energy causes
we've seen this attempt to consolidate
power in dc and i would submit to you
and what we talk about is the fact the
federal government doesn't have this
power you have these enablers in
congress allowing biden to do it and
it's clearly contradictory to the
constitution and it's something i think
that's unprecedented we haven't seen
think about this john this notion that
the federal government the president one
person can order you to inject something
in your body and regardless what do you
think about the vaccine is good or bad
or whatever it doesn't matter it's that
principle that the federal government
one man one person cannot take control
over your body and tell you what you
have to put inside of it so these are
really fundamental principles that we're
fighting for right now and i hope folks
see that i worry about the
politicization of all this issue with
the bite administration but i'm going to
keep fighting i'm going to keep fighting
john so now that this is before the
courts the federal courts at least it is
going to be up to the third branch of
government to make a determination
whether or not this is constitutionally
sound or not wall street journal
editorial board member holman jenkins
wrote about this coincidentally
yesterday saying the good news about the
joe biden vaccine mandates is that
lawyers and judges will now have both
incentive and duty to supply clear
thinking about covet which has been
lacking remember the question before the
courts is not whether vaccines are good
or bad but whether the government has
sufficient authority and grounds to
overrule personal choice in whether to
take them and i think too attorney
general brnovich if you look at the
bigger picture here the trend line for
joe biden on covid is going in the wrong
direction this new quinnipiac poll take
a look at this
48 percent of respondents approve of the
way that the president is handling
coronavirus now compared to 49 who
disapprove well within the margin of
error but again the trend line going in
the wrong direction your thoughts
well john look i'm a public school kid i
didn't go to an ivy league school but i
understand the importance because my
family fled communism of making sure we
have a system of a rule of law and a
government especially a president that
respects the constitution and this is
one of those issues that if you allow
the bidet administration to get away
with this it is an unfettered amount of
power in the hands of any one person any
one administration so i hope the aclu
all these other left-wing groups join
and understand that this is an
incredible invasion not only of our
bodies and our rights to privacy but
it's an overreach by the federal
government and if you allow this
precedent to stand if you allow the
president to do this then what can he
not do it is unfettered power and the
constitution clearly said that was not
his job and this you're right about the
system and the checks and balances with
the judiciary getting involved but let
us not forget that madison the people
who wrote the constitution understood
the states were the ultimate checks in
the federal government that they were
zealously going to guard the liberty and
the rights of their citizen and that's
what we're doing this should be an issue
where there's 50 checks on president
biden and that's all 50 states well we
will see if the aclu and others take you
up on your invitation to join the
lawsuit attorney general brnovich good
to talk to you thanks for laying that
out for us
thank you john